[Music]
[Applause]
he's travis kelsey joins us via zoom and
always great to see him and uh usually
whoa i got the short hair i like that i
like that uh who gave you your haircut
patty cuts baby philly's finest
how much you pay for that
wow man um
you know what i always look out man i
appreciate the the the tight fade
um so any travel so i think just north
of 100
i mean you got good moss why'd you cut
it off
what all this no well everything you
kind of like yeah no i mean just you're
maintaining it man it's just uh
you got to wake up a whole 10 minutes
earlier you know
have you ever work
put
like pomade in your hair have you ever
done something before you played a
football game before the game yeah man i
made that mistake and done it like
before practice or something like that
and i mean you just sweat just right and
now you can't see right yes it's bad
it's real bad no so i had to stop doing
that okay did you not know you were
playing the ravens this sunday night
you know what i knew we had him early i
didn't know it was gonna be the second
game i just didn't put two and two
together you know the ravens were
playing right here why is peyton asking
me this question oh because we're
playing the raider
i'm standing there like i think we got
the chargers now we got the chargers
week three i believe so i was a little
off but i always coach reed always gives
us 24 hours to enjoy the enjoy the win
so once we got back in the building
today um i was i was right on cue with
uh
with who we're playing and i was locked
in okay but does it matter who you're
playing do you do you prepare
differently if you were playing the
chargers as opposed to the ravens
one thousand percent i mean not not
necessarily the the routine the
the mentality that you have going into
the week that kind of stays the same you
have to find that professionalism in uh
making sure that you're always ready for
each individual team but they have
different defenses right so it's just
you understand what teams are doing
differently and you try and attack them
knowing their weaknesses or trying to
find a weakness in what they're doing
would you watch that like did you pick
up anything from the ravens watching
that game they play a lot of man
coverage and they love the blitz it
doesn't matter how many times you heard
them when they do blitz uh they're gonna
keep it coming and um with a team like
that you gotta bring it i know i know
they're gonna be in at home uh sunday
night first game they've had a lot of
people i don't think they had any fans
last year being on the east coast
everything being locked down so i know
that city and that fan base are going to
go nuts a lot of quarterbacks want the
opposition to blitz because that means
somebody's going to be open and it's man
coverage uh yeah i mean what typically
when you blitz there's less guys in the
back end which means there's more hole
more voids
anytime you get a guy like tyreke hill
mandup or you know nicole hartman manned
up with with less guys in the back end i
mean you got to be licking your chops
but i mean they do they're very good at
what they do i mean obviously watching
last night's game they created a lot of
problems for the raiders and i mean it's
uh it's going to be a challenge that's
for sure how many times have you gone to
the line of scrimmage and said this is
going to be a touchdown
too many
too many times where it doesn't it
doesn't end up being a touchdown and i
kick myself um there was another there
was a play there were a few plays uh
this past weekend where you know you
just want to get them back so you can
run the route differently or you know
attack it a different way and uh and end
up in the end zone but it just uh i mean
you learn from it that's why you're
non-stop learning i'm in my ninth year
and i still got a lot to learn in my
mind
was there any added incentive you grew
up in cleveland playing cleveland
i guess you could you could definitely
say that um
it's uh it's ironic that i'm playing
cleveland this week and then and then i
play baltimore the next week because
when i was a child art model
moved the team to baltimore and took
football away from the the city um so
it's uh i don't know it's um i got kind
of a love-hate relationship for both of
them knowing knowing that a lot of my
favorite guys ended up playing for
baltimore and um
well growing up i was i was always a
browns fan did the when the browns left
for baltimore did you cry
i did i did i cried and i remember my
dad took us up to the municipal stadium
it was the last year that they had that
stadium
open downtown and i mean we uh there
were browns players in there it was kind
of like a fan day fan appreciation day
and uh we we went home with some
bleachers in the in the trunk of the car
wait were you supposed to take the
bleachers home
uh it's cleveland baby
exactly act like you know what you're
doing
he's uh travis kelsey the uh kansas city
chiefs tied in joining us on the program
and when you celebrate like when you get
ready to score a touchdown are you
thinking
what am i going to do when i get into
the end zone thank you do you ever think
those kind of out-of-body
experiences
i used to think about it a little bit
more a lot of through my younger years
it was probably premeditated a little
bit more now it's just i just want to
get in there and uh and i got such good
chemistry with the team it usually just
turns into me just getting whacked up in
the head because everyone gets excited
you get get the enzo you go here and all
of a sudden everybody's smacking you
upside the head telling you good job
you're just like hey
all right there it is how about one more
all right
i wondered sometimes you could get hurt
on a celebration because everybody wants
to congratulate you or you get at the
bottom of a pile
yeah no the bottom of the pile i mean
that's uh it's all it's fun until you
really get stuck underneath a couple of
300 pounds so you got to get on make
sure you're off the ground when you're
in the end zone man when did you know
you were in trouble in the super bowl
um probably midway through the third
quarter you start to see where the score
is and you start to see kind of how how
the game's unfolding um
it's just yeah that was probably the the
biggest point time winding down uh we're
running out of time to really make our
make our way back into this game
effectively and uh yeah that was uh that
wasn't the best feeling in the world
because you haven't had that experience
before in a long time i'm guessing
uh you know in a really long time i know
uh we played pittsburgh in i think 2016
and that was really the last time that
we've ever really just got a lot of
points put up on us and as an offense we
didn't do anything
but do you and and
you can't help your line can you because
you've got to be a weapon to get out but
you know your offensive line needs help
against tampa bay like how how do you
kind of
balance that of what do you do when can
you do it give yourself no excuse no
excuses we got great guys out there we
had i i love that offensive line and
everything everything they gave us that
day um and everything before that day
you know they're just it was uh
tama bay came out and they were ready
man they were ready that's all i can say
about is that
on that day they were the better team
man
when's the last time mahomes yelled at
you
um
man i couldn't even tell you oh that's a
good thing it's been a while i think i
think he's never yelled at me
specifically i think he's just yelled at
or got uh uplifting like he was in a
leadership way the entire offense uh
when when things just aren't going our
way and we need a little spark um
indirectly he's he's gotten gotten on a
few people um but
he's he that's what makes him one of the
best leaders and one of the best players
in the league and such a such a guy that
you want to play with and want to play
for and and
um
his ability to to relate to guys and get
the best out of him in in situations
like that is why he's pat mchomes got a
funny story from him in the huddle
um
nothing i can share right now maybe
after my career oh really
i'll spill the beans a little bit
what what's his demeanor like does he
joke does he like joe montana famously
in the super bowl goes oh there's john
candy over there like is
is mahomes that aware of the
surroundings during a game
um i think when we're rolling and he's
feeling good yeah i do think he's much
more aware of his surroundings and likes
to kind of play a little bit more into
the showmanship that is padma homes
showtime of homes um but for the most
part he's a very he's a very locked in
competitor he's thinking about the next
play the next situation uh that's at
hand and the next play call
uh you know i've been trying to get this
usain bolt tyree kill uh you know
sprinting uh you know whatever this race
with these two and i thought he could
put up a gold medal and tyrik puts up
his super bowl ring uh whose side would
you be on
i'm gonna take tyrek hill all day i i've
never seen anybody in person faster than
tyree kill so i'm gonna stick with that
until i see and see it happen okay but
are you willing to put something on it
it's one thing to say you're going to
back your teammate oh yeah no am i
putting my super bowl ring up yeah
i put up my asc championship from last
year
oh so you'll put your afc title your
your ring from that okay
i don't know if usain bolt wants that
ah we'll see we'll see he's got a few
gold medals so i mean he might not care
about one of them maybe you could be the
warm-up race you
you and you versus george kittle in a
warm-up race how's that hey everybody
who wants to see me get
no no no i got you going against george
kittle
oh
candles kiddos will probably give me two
i'm not gonna lie
i like to think that i'm almost as fast
as george but
he's an explosive dude man uh give me
your uh best peyton manning sales pitch
for tide
well i mean didn't peyton set that
standard like peyton is the like the
ideal pitch man here you know it you
know it i mean he's the he was the face
of the nfl for years and obviously tied
working with the the league for years
and years um i'm excited to work with
them on the campaign to get everyone to
turn to cold that's right when you turn
the cold and you don't use hot water
you're saving energy and you're saving
money on the energy bill and it's just
making the planet a better place man and
that's what i'm here for if you go to
tide.com you actually can enter to win a
chance at a
washing machine with my voice over as
you turn too cold and use the cold water
uh you you get until october 5th to
pledge the cold online at ty.com and
everybody who who doesn't want a free
washer man come on now
yes sir let's go okay go all right
all right all right now were you reading
that is there a cue card in front of you
no no only thing i can read right now is
bp studios baby
that's it
hey have fun against baltimore or the
chargers or whoever you play next
yeah whoever we got baby we'll get fired
up and get ready this week man hey great
to talk to you again and uh thanks
always a pleasure dan rock on guys
travis kelsey chiefs tight end
he knows what he's doing he's good